let's jump into the story from the
guardian Ukraine applies for NATO
membership after Russia annexes
territory Vladimir zielinski dismisses
moscow's ceremony as a farce and rules
out negotiations with Putin there you go
there uh there he is he signed the
paperwork I thought it was funny because
like I don't know what that paperwork
says before I know it could be like an
order form for Giordano's or something
you know but he signed it and we watched
him do it and he said it was to join
NATO if Ukraine were admitted into NATO
right now we would formally be in World
War III correct because of Article Five
yes what is the Article Five is that
you've got to defend the new Alice yeah
common defense but if they're already at
War then they wouldn't trigger Article
Five as far as I don't I don't know
actually but I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
sure that effectively that's saying
we're at War and that Russia is now War
the NATO alliance yeah it's a mutual
Alliance pack so if one member of NATO
gets gets attacked all of NATO has to
come in and protect that one particular
country that got attacked but I think
the wage Sorry God I think things work
is if if you're not in NATO when you get
attacked you can't be like oops hey guys
can I rejoin nato in retrospect no you
weren't in NATO people aren't going to
let them in that's the that's the way
this whole conundrum gets solved is that
NATO is not going to admit Ukraine right
you know I I lean towards that because
it seems absurd for and like you need
one NATO member state to be like yeah
but considering the fact that NATO's
basically already involved
I mean it's you know it's one thing to
be already involved is another thing to
be a formerly at War my understanding
curriculum I'm wrong is do
cially say that the attacked Nation gets
to dictate the terms of the of the
assistance I don't know let me let's
let's let's let's pull up Article Five
of NATO right I think and I could be
wrong I thought it was something like
you know if like France is attacked then
France says okay we need help and you
guys are going to supply us with this
is how World War One got started was a
bunch of defensive packs well this is I
want to avoid that I was just going to
say that I was gonna say historians
reading our current history a hundred
years from now are going to be like
these idiots didn't figure out from the
first world war that they shouldn't have
huge alliances and packs and protecting
each other there's a second world war
and a third world war world and of
course there's that famous Einstein
quote about World War III being fought
with weapons that are unknown but World
War four and five being fought with
sticks and stones I'm butchering the
quote here but but you get the gist of
what I'm saying here and this is just an
atrocious situation that is extremely
dangerous for everyone and it's
ridiculous we said World War five world
war four World War World War five yeah
it was like I know not uh I'll pull it
up just because I know not uh what
weapons World War World War III would be
fought with but I know that World War
four will be fought with sticks and
stones yes and then he goes on to say
that world war five is going to be lit
yeah I was like oh wow it's a really
terrible situation I mean it's first off
it's it's terrible that we have Russia
annexing like parts of Ukraine and
saying well this is now Russia because
that's that that puts Putin in a place
where he doesn't have like an easy way
to back down I mean oh that's impossible
right right he can't back down he can't
I mean he can't but neither neither can
any other Russian leader if someone were
to take over after him right kind of
like saying this is what I wanted now
I've got it so leave me alone a little
bit but I mean he's saying that Russian
territory or sorry Ukraine the Ukrainian
territory is now Russian territory and
so I mean it kind of eliminates the
possibility of some sort of complement
territorial compromise uh because you
know ultimately you want Russia you know
I mean you want a negotiated agreement
here I think we all think that's best
because we don't want World nuclear war
if if Putin is uh dying like they say he
is and someone else comes in
that's it what do you do then seed your
newly annexed territory back to Ukraine
you don't liberate it it's also
important to note here that the person
that is uh most most likely to take over
for Putin is more of a Warhawk than he
is we're also in a place where Russia
hasn't officially declared war even
though we are in a in a war obviously
he's still calling it a limited Military
operation but I I do think that that
this setup could be the larger setup for
the use of nuclear weapons smaller
tactical nuclear weapons but also this
could be with his annexation of four new
territories and regions today an excuse
to call out for a full all-out war and
then he's going to attack the
infrastructure he's going to get on the
energy grid and then truly we will see a
very large escalation and and will you
know I I agree with you but I disagree
with you when you said you know NATO is
going to say no because with how crazy
this situation has been already with how
far it has been asked escalating who
knows if if NATO says the situation got
even crazier he used nukes let's just
accept Ukraine right now and just make
it official it I see that as a small
possibility uh but right now unlikely
but who knows what how far we're gonna
go like I think that in the world where
Putin actually did use tactical nuclear
weapons I don't know what NATO would do
and I mean that's a terrifying world I
don't think they retaliate yeah there
was a there's a really funny quote that
I read I can't remember who it was um
who it was from but they said if Russia
were to Nuke a NATO member State NATO
would not respond with a nuclear strike
against Russia they said you would have
to the president would have to be a
Madman to sacrifice Boston for uh what
was it uh what's the what's the Polish
City pausing in pause none pause none
yeah he said you'd have to be a Madman
to sacrifice Boston for posnan well you
know there's a lot of things that we
also have to understand here especially
when it comes comes to our chain of
command
which is in the hands of some very crazy
people uh and and incompetent people and
people who of course don't have their
brains working correctly as well so all
the possibilities are on the table here
and this is why the situation is so
dangerous and it's not just Joe Biden at
the helm here it's individuals like
Victoria Newland who of course have an
agenda to push this conflict to the
furthest extent that she could possibly
see it the United States is answering
today by announcing 12.3 billion dollars
additionally to Ukraine as a part of a
U.S government shutdown Bill Biden also
just announced new sanctions Poland is
handing out radiation pills this is this
is this is crazy as of course there's a
major battle now happening in in Lyman a
major key City that's going to decide
this conflict in in a very Major Way
within the next coming days and and also
there's battles around a Ukrainian power
plant things are are absolutely absurd
and I think they reached a point where I
think there's no going back from it
sadly I wish I there was but this to me
is is is dangerous and extremely
extremely horrible for everyone involved
here so what have you guys done to
prepare for uh nuclear war learn
Cyrillic by man that's one way to start
nice not telling you he's saying it's
for World Peace but the reality is he
thinks Russia is going to win so he's
getting ready to avoid right he's
getting licked at all when we're in the
gulags the actual Russian ones he's
going to be the guy making sure we get
food by talking it's like the man in
High Castle but in Reverse right like
basically like the Russians have taken
over the United States and Ian's found a
position among the the occupying
government I I learned that the best way
to avoid death and destruction and chaos
is diplomacy so I'm rolling with that
one
um what about what about you will have
you built your underground bunker yet no
no I haven't done that I'm still living
in Arlington which seems unwise
that's like the worst place zero yeah
right I don't even think like the world
leaders would be there no I think
they'll you know they'll retire to some
bunker in Oklahoma yeah I don't see the
I don't see world war three here what
are you what were you saying um I do
have a friend with a nuclear bunker
there you go hell yeah yeah a nuclear
just like Bush said it
um I just paid him a visit a couple
weeks ago so he's looking says come on
over I would like to visit just for fun
that'd be cool yeah if you guys want to
come I'm looking at the end shout out to
Joe Buick nice well I'm looking at what
actually got annexed it's for uh what is
called oblasts donuts I don't know how
you pronounce it
Crimean 2014 but what it does is it
takes Highway M14 which is the East West
Highway from Russia and it goes east or
Goes West rather to it also took Highway
East 105 and East 97 that go north south
so he took the East-West Highway that
connects to these two north-south
highways that take you down out of
Crimea they want a Trade Post in
sevastopol that's the whole point is to
be able to move military and trade stuff
into the Mediterranean at this point I
don't understand why they're not in NATO
with us and one of our best trade allies
they have so much resources they're a
federation like the United States it's a
Federated group of states well
strategically geopolitically China is
also emerging as a power that is
threatening American hegemony and if you
were uh you know calling American
foreign policy I think it would be in
the best interest to have good relations
with either of those countries in order
to make sure that they don't come
together I think we've done the opposite
of that and I think we're creating a
situation that that truly is
highlighting a West versus East
situation which is not beneficial to
anyone it has to be on purpose you know
I'm I'm in many circumstances well
beyond believing in coincidence and
considering what Joe Biden's how he's
been very favorable or deferential to
China this greatly benefits China yeah
you know the US and Russia fighting some
some have actually argued I think we're
talking about the other day that China
may have been the one who sabotaged
Nordstrom to force Russia and NATO to
fight so that they could then make a
move on time I could see that I could
see I mean I could see a third you know
third parties who wanted to just inflame
things further yeah and that that that
makes sense to me it makes more sense to
me than Russia doing it which just is
completely ridiculous but they're saying
they're saying there are a bunch of
articles that it was like people are
pushing conspiracy theories that the
West destroyed the North Street and
they're all citing Anonymous government
sources saying 100 it was Russia 100 I'm
like where's the evidence where's the
proof and and the person even saying
this is not putting their name behind
this a part of the US government
intelligence agencies that of course
everyone's naming as a source who's the
source I I tweeted I said so let me get
this straight the official narrative is
that Russia their own Pipeline and not
say their enemies who they're currently
at war with like that's just nuts if I
see two guys and they're screaming at
each other and they're like you know if
I ever see I'm Gonna Knock You Out and
then the guy is found knocked out
outside of the other dude's house I'm
not gonna be like he must hit himself
that's yeah right I mean Biden said he
would yeah he said it he's like oh yeah
we'll make Nordstrom go away and then
when and where he was like oh other guy
did that not me what what I love the
media it's just it's you know maybe this
is where it's become so laughably absurd
that people just can't accept it anymore
yeah David Frum had a thing he had a
tweets thread where he was talking about
how he wrote an article called
unpatriotic conservatives back in 2003
about people who opposed a rock you know
who were correct about that absolutely
um and now he's like yeah the
unpatriotic conservatives are back my
article age really well and it's the
people who are you know doubting the U.S
intelligence Services account that
um Russia blew up its own pipeline yeah
imagine the hubris right just the level
of one you can't be if you question our
intelligence agencies which have been
routinely wrong and also lied to
Americans routinely then you are not
patriotic or you are I mean it's the the
number of different like logical leaps
you have to take to get to David from's
reasoning I I would even push back I
wouldn't say they were wrong I think
they were deliberately lying I think
they had an agenda they had profits that
they wanted to get they had people that
they needed to please and I think they
deliver he said yeah they got wmds when
they knew they didn't as of course the
United States government also had the
receipts to the chemical weapons that
they were selling to Iraq when Iraq was
fighting with Iran and what did the war
in Iraq do well it created Isis it
allowed Iran to have a larger sphere of
influence in the entire Middle East it
allowed of course the destruction and
the death of what people estimated to be
over a million people why did we do this
wmds yeah I don't know I'm reading I'm
reading a book about the CIA right now
which is actually very good and and the
the overall lesson of this book so far
is that the CIA has a reputation for
like secrecy and competence but it's
actually just absurdly stupid and has
made huge mistakes I think you know
early in the Cold War what they did
their their whole plan was like we're
going to create these little partisan
armies and all the Communist States and
they just dropped it like dropped
partisans you know and and refugees they
just dropped them in or like go
infiltrate the government and they all
died all the agents they they just all
died like all of them everywhere like in
the Korean War they dropped a bunch of
Koreans into North Korea all of them
captured killed everyone yeah just one
comment really quickly if I was the CIA
I would be also pretending to be really
stupid in order to cover for all my
illegal actions and horrible crap that I
did thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there